I mean at the time there wasn't a lot
that had been discussed the history was
so recent that apart from what was in
the news there hadn't been a lot of
in-depth books written him really none
actually so we had to kind of generate
our own source material and do a lot of
research out of really out of necessity
and so we just went and talked to a lot
of people and gathered string until we
felt like we had enough of background in
the subject so once you get the
background how did you figure out your
point of view and how to get into the
story how to tell the story a lot of
women had worked on this hunt if you
will and that there was one woman in
particular who played a fairly decisive
role and then it at a certain point you
kind of put all the research aside and
you say to yourself like okay I still
have to write a screenplay this is a
movie it's a motion picture it's a
hopefully it's a work of Dramatic Art
and so you start thinking about things
in terms of story and character and
momentum and narrative and when that
phase of the process happened the Maya
character was was born out of a
real-life analogue out of a real life
person but the decisions to kind of
focus on her work you know as I think
they should be creative you know what we
were trying to tell a very contemporary
story in a very contemporary way and for
me I mean that will mean different
things to different people but for me
that means maybe letting go of some of
the dramatic tropes that that people
normally deploy to make something seem
convincing no from the from the very
beginning we wanted the point of view to
feel like real and to feel like the
audience was watching something that was
real and I think audiences are more may
be down for that then then then in an
olden times let's say and I think people
are so accustomed to so much information
being dumped at them and really the
audiences today are so media savvy a lot
of these scenes in this movie are it's
more about subtext it's all and this we
also we're also getting this whole this
idea of it's a bunch of people in a room
in a very low-tech way and that's how
they found it's not sort of fancy
computers and you know it's people
working hard
see in a fit of grungy room and that's
that's kind of how it how it all goes
down and not you know supercomputers
doing all this work so it does set the
stage that's the first scene in the
movie after all the enhanced
interrogation scene so it really does
set the stage for sort of what you're
about to see these always people just
like doing their job every day for ten
years it feels contemporary to me to not
to trust the audience's intelligence and
not lay everything out for them and to
use subtext and to assume that you might
not really know who much con is you
might not really care but you're you're
going to be able to pick up the story
and clue and like stay clued in as time
goes on I don't know that feels for some
reason maybe more contemporary than
spelling everything out like once upon a
time there was somebody named Osama bin
Laden and these are the people that
found and also not talk down to them I
mean that if you were in that room
nobody would stop and explain things to
you so part of the naturalism and
realism is not having characters turn to
each other and say you know maje con
that guy that we talked about last week
who's kind of important but not critical
so like we don't have to really focus on
like that's you once you do that kind of
exposition you sort of cut against the
naturalism that you're trying to achieve
so audiences now can can can follow they
sort of have let go this need to be what
they show them to shop or whatever the
over the shoulders and stay on the same
side of the line and I mean people don't
even talk about the line anymore it's
it's it's the who cares I know that guy
in the sweater okay good gotta keep
going and and it it is that they they
they want to get to they're trusting us
as filmmakers to highlight the thing
they really need to pay attention to and
so from a from a you know a craft point
of view we have to keep that in mind we
go to night at bin Laden's compound and
the decision was to shoot at night as
night which is a challenging thing to
try to do in a movie so we were moving
back and forth between a moonless night
and the night vision of the soldiers who
are invading the compound the thing it
was clear to me from the beginning was
that all these solar is dark obviously
and the soldiers are all wearing the
same uniform and they have night vision
goggles on and they all kind of look the
same
so how do we let the audience know where
we are and the start compound where even
I well I was cutting it was confusing so
we came up with his you know Catherine
brilliantly I mean shot a lot of point
of view from the sniper snipers point of
view who's up on this prayer room so we
used him for the interior the comment we
use him as a sign post and and we were
able to establish him and we went away
we came back generally to him when we're
in that part of the compound and used
his point of view to sort of root the
audience and where we were and then
we're on the exterior we use of the main
gate as our signpost there so because it
was just impossible to know where
everybody is and I think again with this
more modern filmmaking or if you want to
call it that the audience is they I
would be interested to know if you
picked one hundred people and ask them
say tell me exactly what happened and
they might some of them may know every
detail and some of them may know hath of
details but because of the intensity of
it because of their willingness to go
along with it because they're gripped by
the story I think they fill in a fill in
blanks for you